ahh!! bahh!! bahhh!!  ah, im dying. BAH (poor pewds)
nothing is working my business .....is failing
family friendly Felix is not....
working out enough:((
I keep swearing , (burps) I keep being disgusting
and I keep being too sexy ( pewds sexy time )
you know everyone seems to quit buzzfeed
these days so it must be in pretty open market
work it but it should be...
it should be easy enough BuzzFeed is the
leading independent digital media ..mhm
London!
oh my god the fucking cringe get ready( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
for the most exciting opportunity of your
life yaaas yaaaas guys I'm gonna get a job
at BuzzFeed yaaas yaaas
*very very loud horn...* (R.I.P headphone users)
I think family friendly Felix can really find its home
at BuzzFeed the most innovative company
in the world okay I want to work in
video oh shit I guess I gotta move to LA
now okay so they want me to attach my
resume I think I should just send them
my most quality content some of the
finest work that I ever done this one
I've always wanted to share
take when BuzzFeed hear that shit
they're gonna wish they could create
content as cringy as mine
here we go share how do I attach it I
need to picture okay okay well let's try
and find a high-quality picture of
myself LinkedIn profile uh website links
for fall okay I guess
YouTube preferred well bless them how do
you hear about this job desperation
what if your desired salary
realistically a million III legit if
BuzzFeed offered me a million a month I
would take that shit no doubt gender
decline how dare you please identify
your race American Indian or Alaska
native Asian like I spent at White
Hawaiian two or more races wheres the who
gives a shit option
alright we're submitting, ahh the gifs again
the gifs, we got damn it I can't wait
for their response
I can't wait for their response, in the
meanwhile let's see what other people
are saying about BuzzFeed the greatest
website of all tiime, why I left BuzzFeed
why I left buzfeed why I left bus to
feed why we left Buzzfeed why I left but
why I left BuzzFeed, why i left BuzzFeed
the truth about working at BuzFeed, why I
left Buzzfeed, these channels have
millions of subscribers now, what the ff
they're all leaving at once no Chris
Sofia I was looking forward to working
with these people god dammit, (Person on video) I wanted to
continue making videos on this channel
and to see how I could grow this channel
and see what more I could do with it but
while I was making so many videos at
BuzzFeed and while I was working there
you know eight hours everyday it was
there for nine hours every day that
doesn't leave a lot of time to work on
projects outside of BuzzFeed and not
only does it not leave a lot of time but
you're not allowed to work on projects
outside of BuzzFeed I know there's been
a lot of controversy over that lately -
(Felix) any big company any, literally any big
company doesn't allow their employees to
work on the same thing you're working
there on you're there to work for them
that's why you get paid why is that a
thing who gives a shit it's the same
thing like if you work for EA or any
company you can't make your own games in
the spare time if you make, you can
but you can't publish it while you're
working on under yeah you're supposed to
make games for them that's why you're
hired
it's like you can't have the cake and
eat it at the same time, it should..Why is that
a controversy and it sounds to me like
you got your YouTube channel
kick-started from the BuzzFeed thing so
what's the fucking problem nowadays all
you've got to do is join BuzzFeed be in
a handful of vids then leave and boom
instant traffic to your new already own
channel that's exactly what happened
what are you bitching about bought and
(guy on video) all this stuff you know pressure from a
quota feeling like there's no growth
wanting to work on my own content that
all started to make me very unhappy and
very very unhappy and I started to not
look forward to coming to work every day
and I started to just
(Felix) how do you work at
a media company about making videos and
you can't make this fucking video
interesting goddamn I'm bored, for fuck's
sake man (guy on video) laganja estranja
yeah god honey in her studio the drag
Estravaganga
and I'm gonna get done up in drag
(Felix) Hasnt BuzzFeed done this like a
billion times already see I don't even
like BuzzFeed but I'm beginning to side
with them now look at these whiny
bitches man look how happy these people
are at BuzzFeed, look how happy she is
what are you saying you're not happy at
BuzzFeed, she's smiling oh look how happy she
is, well maybe not him, oh look how happy
she is, oh my god they're all happy happy
happy happy (Allison) so that question is why did
we leave BuzzFeed we left over a year
ago so this is probably one of the
scariest decisions you've ever had to
make
I agree the first week (Felix) seems really
scared to quit your job when it will guarantee
you millions of views on YouTube (chuckles)
(Allison) thing about jobs is that you can leave
them (Felix) what is what what do you mean
(Allison) the thing about jobs is that you can leave them
(Felix) please follow that up with
something intellectual (Allison) The point is even if the
company's great even if like you had
great experience there if it's no longer
the right fit like in a relationship
then you have to break up
(Felix) The thing about jobs to say you can leave them, yes, I
get it now
Why, why am I still here
just to suffer, (chuckles) are you telling me I
should leave it I don't have to be here
(Gabby) you work for a company and make videos
everything that you make that company
own so for instance
(Felix) again that's why
you're getting paid
what are you but ah don't make me side
with BuzzFeed stop
(Gabby) if you might have
heard about some people being let go
from BuzzFeed and those people the
characters and the videos that they the
series that they created while it must
be they'll never be able to make that
series ever again
(Felix) then don't make it for BuzzFeed well my
real question is is why there's all
these people having steady jobs as
BuzzFeed why do they want to come to
YouTube don't they know what it's like
Buzzfeed run while you can, get out while you can
so now BuzzFeed, you know it's gotten
so so bad so much bad rep that they they
had to change the name of their channel
BuzzFeed yellow is now Bold..ly,
Boldly (Kelsey) its the same videos you know and love
I get like having an open mind to like not
just straight white male every time all
right I get that but this just seems
like put forcing it in doesn't it okay
here's my BuzzFeed video they always
have like this fucking background can we
get some BuzzFeed background something
BuzzFeed will normally do they always
try shit right well I got this breast
pump so today we're going to try it hate
hey guys
family-friendly Felix here for BuzzFeed
working here at BuzzFeed,
love BuzzFeed
by the way best website of all time now
today I'm going to try out the breast
pump it's made for females to lactate
their nipples during pregnancy but I'm
gonna use it as a male
hilarious, right
that is the pinnacle of comedy
anything
that girls do guys do
Shit............daddy's gonna like this
okay all right all right so let's get
let's get the nips in place BuzzFeed I
hope you're watching wait...How do I
there we go okay
can't seem to get them on place
oh my nipples are huge
oh my god they're so big ah okay let's
try the let's try the vibration nah (laughs)
looks like my nipple is about to explode
can we get a close-up
do you see that
shit do you fucking see that shit boy ah
ah ahit hurts get him up oh
so anyway guys
be sure to leave a like and subscribe
for more family-friendly Felix content
and I swear I'm not going to quit after
a while and just make a YouTube channel
that would be I'm dedicated to this job
and I think I can say BuzzFeed